hey guess what a few weeks ago I
finished the Esperanto skill tree on
duolingo as you can see right here from
the Golden Calf uh I mean owl sorry
hello everyone welcome to the Lang
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today I want to talk about duolingo it's
an application for learning languages
that now has over 100 million users I've
been using it for a few months and it's
really an effective way to learn a
language for free or so they say nothing
in this world comes for free and using
duolingo comes at a price quite a steep
price that you need to be aware of when
using duolingo you sometimes encounter
some very strange sentences some of
these sentences are complete nonsense
but others seem to be a very clear
reference to the dark disturbing side of
human nature some people say that these
sentences are just luck or they result
from random word combinations but I beg
to differ there are far too many of
these bizarre strange translations for
it to be simple luck
the truth is duo wants to possess your
soul
[Music]
you don't believe me let me prove it to
you the first thing you may notice is
that duolingo is trying to blur the
lines between human beings and animals
the bare hands the beer - a catch the
birds drink beer hmm cats drink milk and
beer the duck is drinking wine well by
this point you're probably imagining
yourself sitting back having a drink
with a bunch of animals which makes you
little more than a simple animal doesn't
it you drink my cat's milk
well that really just is an odd
statement isn't it the squirrel is our
captain the girl follows the Bears
example so humans according to duolingo
you are supposed to copy what animals do
because you should be an animal just
like them I am a snake we do not know
who is human duolingo wants to convince
you that you are the same as an animal
rather than a spiritual being they want
you to revert back to your animal
impulses and your wild instinct they
continue this process of spiritual
destruction by killing your self-esteem
hmm you are stupid well thank you
duolingo you are useless you eat like a
pig
you have no culture mmm well that's
really just a low blow now isn't it now
you have no friends you have rings under
your eyes yours is small well yeah it
probably is a little small but you
didn't have to point that out thank you
you are just average sometimes I doubt
your intelligence man I am a loser you
know what I'm kind of starting to feel
like that after reading all these
sentences when you have no self-esteem
you will easily begin to hate others
what the duo demons do next is make you
feel contempt for other people no one is
good my parents are aggrieved here's a
nice little cynical statement she loves
him for his wealth your niece is stupid
your parents are strange his head is
bigger than a football hmm a little
judgmental now aren't we duolingo
I do not like the rich hmm once duolingo
makes you hate yourself and hate other
people now you are all alone and they
are free to shape your
next they flood your mind with bizarre
and grotesque imagery to cut your old
connection with reality and begin
pulling you over to the dark side the
bear gave birth to a duck the boy eats
23 beetles now that's something I just
don't want to even imagine the engineer
is in the refrigerator now I'm imagining
this engineer in pieces in the
refrigerator so this is getting kind of
creepy I am eating an elephant hmm okay
poaching eating endangered animals do
you import people hmm
human trafficking that sounds like the
way to go that is not water it is yellow
sorry I'm eating a rabbit the cat lays
the mouse into the milk what the hell
for the kid eats insects and this guy
just looks so happy about that a tiger
is eating my husband the wolf eats me do
animals have blood well yes they do but
we don't usually focus on it unless we
have to
now that you are fully open to
manipulation duolingo fills you with a
fascination for death and violence how
does an animal die I am going to die why
is the kitchen full of blood well that's
probably cuz there was a double homicide
I am ready to die hmm
well I'm not so please don't make me
repeat this sentence over and over you
shall bleed defeat the babies hmm and
exactly in what context are we fighting
these babies she will go to hell hmm I'm
starting to think we're all going to
help it is necessary that the husband
dies he has to die and look she's so
happy about it isn't murder fun why do
you have so many wounds on your body hmm
well it could be because I've spent the
last hour killing husbands and wild
animals on duolingo soon they will shoot
look how excited this woman is by that
incoming onslaught of firepower you can
die hmm we all commit crimes at times
where were you at the time of the murder
now duolingo knows that they're probably
going to get you into some trouble so
they're just preparing you for that
inevitable interrogation once your mind
is filled with violence then you are
just a single step away from committing
acts of violence while Duo watches and
laughs the last step is designed to
ensnare your soul permanently because of
its addictive nature duolingo seeks to
fill your soul with sexual immorality
you must be especially careful when
learning these sentences may i kiss you
well this one seems innocent enough but
of course it's a slippery slope
my boyfriend eats in the bedroom the boy
pleases the girls hmm yeah this is
something we really shouldn't be
thinking about but you know I guess it's
not that bad he's pleasing them he's
making them feel good you drink a man's
juice hmm well no I don't but I guess
there are some people out there who do
he has a big black sack
he likes balls hmm well to each his own
I am NOT your toy yes I know the feeling
it's kind of frustrating isn't it I eat
your pink strawberry
I have zero pants okay these these cards
are still bad they're still obviously
the work of
devil but maybe they're not as bad as
the others I guess we should still be
careful though the lawyer is being
washed by his secretary
yeah I know this one is kind of bad but
it sounds kind of fun too
you know she raises her shirt hmm yeah
sometimes women do that um I I shouldn't
look when they do but you know she takes
my sugar she wants to taste my crepes
hmm you sleep between them well yeah
sometimes it's fun to sleep with
multiple people that nothing dodgy
they're just putting sleeping you need
to get out of here before my husband
arrives hmm well this situation sounds
kind of adventurous or exciting well so
you see that duolingo comes up with a
lot of interesting sentences of course
it's good to be careful but maybe it's
not really such a big deal after all
like you have to have a sense of humor
right and of course you should enjoy
your life and seek pleasure shouldn't
you after all you only live once and
then you die if God wanted us to be so
spiritual and why did he give us these
animal instincts you know duolingo
really is quite fun there's something
special about it I don't quite know what
it is but I have a special feeling and I
don't know where it comes from I just
know that you should probably try
duolingo very soon and you should
probably use it everyday as much as you
can
you'll learn many things right do Oh
[Music]
thanks for watching everyone if you
enjoyed this video then please like or
share it especially with other fans of
duolingo and if you yourself have found
some interesting funny or strange
sentences inside duolingo then please
write those in the comments down below
and we'll be sure to check them out
thank you for watching have a nice day
[Music]